so many kids want you to be their wish
how hard is that I'll bring them all
over bring more let's do this there's no
more as many as we can let's do it
always make time today Kobe Bryant had
such a big heart and as a matter of fact
he was honored for his longtime work
with the make-a-wish Foundation in 2013
I have to tell you that Kobe cared as
much about his philanthropy as he did
his basketball and I had a chance to see
it firsthand when he made an ailing fans
wish come true it's beyond the game you
know we're all blessed to do what we do
and you know there's a greater purpose
to that in 2006 I had the privilege to
witness one of the more than 200 make a
wishes Kobe granted over the course of
his career and I'm gonna be second half
I was one of his wishes and least had to
do to come out here and meet my man
Carlos and beautiful family and just
kind of kick back for a day and just
just enjoy each other's time treatment
from pancreatic cancer left Carlos week
and it was difficult for him to speak so
how amazing is it to have Kobe Bryant
Kobe took his time playing video games
and signing every single piece of Lakers
gear he brought along by the end of the
visit Carlos had the strength to stand
and hug his hero goodbye pleasure to
meet you man
he passed away just two days later the
situation is very serious and they just
wanted me kids take pictures and sign
autographs and play catch play chess and
you know whatever it is make-a-wish was
just one of the ways Kobe was such a
star off the court with his wife the
Kobe and Vanessa Bryant Family
Foundation worked tirelessly to put an
end to youth homelessness they also
provided educational resources to rich
the lives of children in 2018 et saw
Toby make a surprise appearance to hand
out books and spend time inside the
classroom of this LA area school the way
we do it is through action you do it
right and you be an example of that my
wife and I we try to do that on a
consistent basis versus simply telling
them to do it if you actually live it
[Music]